حسن ولعلي سانطرح من هذه التطورات تحديدا
في خان يونس الجيش الاسرائيلي كان منذ
بضعه اسابيع قد اعلن عن تكثيف زخم هجماته
خصوصا في المنطقه الوسطى ولكن اكد على ان
هذه الهجمات ستكون اكثر تركيزا في المناطق
الجنوبيه نحن نشير بالاساس الى خان يونس
خان يونس التي تشي بتطور تطوراتها اليوم
من خلال ما اعلنه الجيش الاسرائيلي قال
بانه عم مقا من هجماته وايضا توغلات وايضا
وسعها في خان يونس هذه التوغ لت التي تقوم
بها الكتيبه او الفرقه رقم 98 وتضم سبعه
الويه ياتي بينما كان هذا التوغل في بدايه
ديسمبر قد انطلق من المناطق الشرقيه ولكن
ايضا من المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه نتذكر
كيف كانت الانطلاقه من خزاعه وايضا من
عبسان وك كان الاتجاه نحو بني سهيله في
محاوله ايضا للوصول الى شارع صلاح الدين
لكن اللافت هو ان هذه التطورات التي
اعلنها الجيش الاسرائيلي قال بعباره بانها
تتم هذا التوغل ياتي كما افاد مراسلنا
الياس كرام ببطء وحذر شديدين التوغل
الاسرائيلي ربما اذا ذهبنا الى الخريطه
بالشكل اكثر تفصيلا هذه المره ياتي من
المناطق الشماليه ولكن ايضا من المناطق
الشماليه ولكن ايضا من المناطق الشماليه
الغربيه كان هناك استهداف بالاساس ل
مستشفى الامل ولكن كان ايضا هناك استهداف
لمستشفى ناصر وايضا كان هناك محاوله
للتقدم عبر محاور عديده من بينها شارع
خمسه و مع العلم بان القوات الاسرائيليه
كانت متمركزه في السابق حينما توغلت من
بني تيله هنا في مقر البلديه اذا تطورات
لافته هنا في هذه المنطقه والهدف هو
محاوله السيطره على المنطقه الوسطى حينما
نتحدث عن المنطقه الوسطى نحن نتحدث عن قلب
خان يونس توغل اسرائيلي معلن ولكن ايضا
ياتي في ظل اشتباكات خضتها المقاومه على
اكثر من صعيد وعلى اكثر من جبهه نحن نتحدث
عن شبه مربع ربما مساحته لا تتجاوز الخم
كيلومترات مربعه تحاول القوات الاسرائيليه
التقدم نحوه بالحديث عن مستشفى نصر ربما
نشير الى بعض التحذيرات من ان سيناريو
الشفاء الذي شهدته منطقه الشمال يحاول
الجيش الاسرائيلي تكراره هنا في خانيونس
اذا جبهه ملتهبه في الجنوب ربما لا تقل
عنها التهابا ايضا جبهه في الشمال حيث
نشير باختصار الى عمليات القصف التي طالت
تل الزعتر وتبعنا مشاهد مؤلمه ولكن ايضا
حديث عن اشتباكات تاخذها المقاومه في
الشيخ رضوان وايضا منطقه النصر وعمليات
ايضا قصف لمنازل هنا في حي الزيتون هذه
ابرز التطورات حسن ربما على الجبهه
الشماليه ولكن ابرزها كان في خان يونس
شكرا جزيلا لك